d'abord j'espère que le sénat va
améliorer c'est d'abord bilan des
courses on devait avoir la grande
révolution qu'à les rendre simples la
formation professionnelle qui allait
améliorer les conditions d'accès et donc
la quantité de formation opérer en
france on n'a rien de tout ça on devait
avoir une universalité notamment pour
les travailleurs indépendants
l'indemnisation chômage bilan des
courses s'il y en a quinze mille qui
vont être travailleur indépendant qui
vont être concernés
ce sera le boudu le bout du bout on nous
expliquait aussi que ce qui ferait
faillite or est une opportunité je crois
que c'est 3000 face à un nombre
dérisoire que tout ça est de la poudre
aux yeux pour ce qui est des engagements
de campagne d'emmanuel maquereau en
revanche il ya une grande
déstabilisation du système sans qu'on
ait construit quelque chose qui fasse
adhésion entre les collectivités locales
les régions les syndicats et même le
patronat nous avons entendu nos
collègues sénateurs de cette quittent
sur ce dossier ont écouté les syndicats
mais ils sont unanimes pour dire que
c'est que c'est négatif et même le medef
alors on va le dire si les syndicats le
medef sont pas d'accord c'est que c'est
bien maintenant parce que pour réussir
la formation professionn dans ce pays il
faut que les travailleurs sociaux soit
les travailleurs le dialogue social soit
opérant et que les partenaires sociaux
soient impliqués partager la grande
région par exemple devant les cfa
disparaître dans certaines régions ah
ben oui on a autour de 700 cfa qui
pourraient disparaître alors bon c'est
quand une marchandisation
on va plus avoir un service d'intérêt
général gérés par les régions en lien
avec les chambres consulaires avec toute
une série de partenaires qu'il fallait
sans doute amélioré parce que
l'apprentissage est une voie qu'il faut
soutenir mais là ça va être le marché
mise en opéra piloté par les branches
professionnelles alors le pilotage par
les branches professionnelles ça me fait
doucement rigoler pourquoi parce que on
ne cesse de nous dire qu'il ya trop de
branches
donc avant de donner aux branches c'est
les fans avant de donner aux branches la
gestion qu'on rationalise les bandes les
branches
il ya six ans branches professionnelles
donc tout ça va être une pagaille sans
nom moi je d'abord je pense quand même
que
l'apprentissage et de la formation
initiale donc elle doit rester sous un
pilotage public
je n'ai absolument rien contre
l'intervention des partenaires sociaux
des branches professionnelles faut que
cet apprentissage ils collent bien aux
besoins
tout ça est vrai j'ai été vice président
de la région nord pas de calais pour la
forme professionnelle la formation
professionnelle c'est très important
qu'on colle bien aux attentes
en même temps voilà donc oui le sénat
doit obtenir que les régions soient de
mieux associer que tout ça soit beaucoup
plus progressif dans la mise en oeuvre
si on veut mieux associer les branches
professionnelles et on doit aussi
veiller à ce que la formation derrière
la réorganisation soit pas une chute des
dotations
vous savez en réalité le compte
professionnel le cpf qui remplace tout
ça va faire que chacun va avoir moins
en réalité on l'entend en tout cas vous
allez